you guys
uh came up in the 90s in terms of making
movies and getting in the limelight
nowadays you know you have social media
is instant when people are doing
anything it's on social media it's being
reported when you guys were in the
limelight in the 90s it was like weekly
magazines covering what stars were doing
do you think you would have been able to
you know take it back then this question
came out bad but hopefully you
understand it oh i totally understand
you're saying and you're making me think
of something i hadn't thought of before
actually which is that
it makes my job way harder if people
intimately know who i just plain at how
are you supposed to believe that i'm
somebody else in some other situation
you know when you know what i had for
breakfast this morning and what it
sounds like when i left earlier you're
like i don't know what this that's a
terrible example but like people just
expose their whole lives on social media
and it's in this pursuit of seeming as
transparent and as knowable as possible
and that's really antithetical to what
we do
right yeah it's a great answer i mean i
also think that look i think both of us
would have been fine because neither one
of us were like out partying and it's
not the world we grew up in i mean
that's not certainly not the hollywood i
grew up in like i still play dungeons
and dragons i grew up you know doing
playing and doing plays and in drama and
going to theater school so i was never
in this space to be
sort of a wild man so i would have been
fine in that respect but i and and it's
also like it does feel finicky like who
gets found and why you get followed
i don't know if i ever would have been
an addison ray who is this
her own industry i mean she's a major
industry and i don't know if i could
ever have done what she does it's a
full-time job yeah people certainly
would not have been interested in any
kind of content i can't really dance
like her either she's so dance but i am
tick talking i started to tic tac
tic tacking i'm tic-tacking
nobody's gonna follow me this is stupid
i will i keep trying to do
i'll show you i'm about to tick-tock us
go ahead next question as a tick-tock
uh i am curious what it was like for the
two of you though when you stepped on
set for the first time making this movie
realizing that you're the parents
in this situation when you know what i
mean
i'm sorry
he's asking a serious question i know it
was very helpful i can't wait to see
your answer about how mature and
grown-up we are
the two shots you're directing this
interview
you know something though this is listen
i've been in some very bland and boring
interviews i'll take this every day of
the week no one's ever here
no
sorry give it the smart answer was it
weird going to work the first time it
was a little are you scared it was a
little weird you nervous i think i did
feel a little well it's it's also really
hard going
onto a set after everybody's sort of
like in the groove already you feel like
you're sort of like playing in somebody
else's yard a little bit you take a
minute to find your footing see what the
set dynamics feel like make sure you
know the exact tone of the movie et
cetera et cetera so you always feel like
a little bit funny your first day at
least i do so in that sense come you
know combined with the fact that i was
like revisiting something intensely
familiar to me yeah it was a pretty
weird first day on set but then i
realized that i was in a very friendly
space and i think it was a really great
experience all in all
yeah i mean for me it was humbling right
you're you're
joining a group i mean i literally was
on the last three days of the movie so i
like the
it was like being at thanksgiving dinner
and showing up for the pie i mean i was
like everyone was like i'm like what
where's what's happening were the inside
jokes
but it was very sweet because i feel
like
that
you know the whole cast was super
respectful and
were earnestly like excited that i was
there had all seen the movie had all
grown up with scooby-doo like they were
very sweet and very like open about they
were gushing about the fact that i was
there so
it felt
yeah it felt like i was it was humbling
right and it's such a look at such an
iconic role in my life in my career so
to go back for me was sweet and i i
actually really
cherished it in a weird way it was
really
it was fun and
humbling
i'm actually curious when you guys think
back on she's all that what's like one
or two of the big memories that always
comes to like your mind you know in
terms of making the movie yeah i mean
personally i mean i always think about
paul walker and god bless the soul but
like he was it was like his first film
and
he was i have very clear memories of him
freddie and i and dulay sitting there
talking and hanging out so that's one
thing that's
a sweet memory and then the dance scene
for me was a big piece of my life where
i'll walk in and that song will play and
like sort of the whole room will like
look at me to see if i'm gonna do the
dance
so it's like you know those two pieces
of my life and then my first date
with my wife who i'm still married with
like a hundred years later i was in the
middle of doing that movie and so
so he had like the fake tattoos all over
him and like they weren't fake i like to
go full he's real they're real yeah
i like to get into my roles so that's a
real tattoo it says me and it's pretty
badass
i should redraw that and that's why i
should tick-tock i should put that on my
tick-tock that would be the case
we're gonna blow this thing up we're
gonna go we're going big ass and ray
look out sorry what's your what's your
memories
well
were you there yeah you were there and
usher was there right sir sure right so
like his
i remember that you make me want i was
the first like cd disc single i had like
ever bought i was like
is he here
hello number one on the call sheet i
don't know if you've seen me
yes i remember we were i've been made
over we were filming the prom scene
and it was like we were in this gym and
there's just way too many like
background everybody people ever it's
it's really hot back there and tamara
mello who plays like uh one of my
antagonists in the movie
was standing next to me and usher was
next to her and he goes
oh it's pretty hot in here and tamara
goes you should probably take your shirt
off and he did
no
he did not yeah stop it
nobody ever says that next to me
nobody's ever said matt
super hot take your shirt off
thank you so much
[Laughter]
thank
reason you go just pay the black
they're gonna do it aren't they